in a world where nobody makes mistakes
there might never be a need for
superheroes but in the real world nobody
is perfect including the men and women
who made the Marvel Cinematic Universe
from the Avengers to x-men the folks
behind our favorite superhero movies are
just as human as the rest of us and here
are a few mistakes you might have needed
supervision to spot
Deadpool strange selfies Deadpool's
plans don't often go exactly as he's
intended I forgot my ammo bag shall we
turn back no no time I got this 9 10 11
12 bullets or Boston right here and
apparently neither do his selfies during
one of the fleeting happy moments in the
pre-super life of Wade Wilson he takes a
cuddly photo with his lady but when we
see the actual Polaroid both the poses
and the smiles are completely different
and it's not the only time Deadpool's
pictures make a sudden change
Deadpool the evolving self-portrait
during Deadpool's elaborate opening
sequence we see a tattered burning
sketch that shows our antihero using
swords to decapitate a nameless bad guy
but when Deadpool creates the crayons
self-portrait later he's using guns and
the rest of the doodle has changed
Napoleon Dynamite wouldn't have made
that mistake gosh iron man Peppers
high-tech headset Tony Stark may be a
billionaire playboy with next-level
technology but even he doesn't have
invisible bluetooth headsets however his
assistant Pepper apparently does after a
quick cut away in iron man the wireless
headset she's wearing during a phone
call disappears faster than Terrence
Howard disappeared from the cast of Iron
Man 2 Wow
next time
the amazing spider-man 2 the amazing
backpack Peter Parker obviously has a
lot of stuff to deal with and can't be
expected to know what's going on with
his accessories at all times
after just barely making it to Gwen
Stacy's graduation ceremony in the
amazing spider-man 2 his backpack
repeatedly jumps from one shoulder to
both with great power comes well lousy
continuity ant-man gun fever one of the
many upsides to being ant-man is that
you're able to control swarms of ants
with your mind that comes in
particularly handy when the villainous
Darren cross holds a gun to the head of
ant-man and an army of ants jammed the
guns firing hammer however the type of
pistol cross is holding throughout the
scene doesn't have the external revolver
type hammer that's shown in the close-up
but let's hear it for those noble at
setting way gambits receding facial hair
there's no shortage of hairy man in
Wolverines world but gambit takes it to
the extreme in x-men origins Wolverine
when he encounters Wolverine in a bar
he's got a scruffy mustache and beard
but after knocking Wolverine through a
wall he's suddenly far more clean-shaven
making it clear this scenes were shot on
different days spider-man don't turn
around
sometimes the science behind
spider-man's web slinging is a little
iffy but it's not Spidey who breaks the
laws of physics here during a scene in
spider-man in which large chunks of
building a scene about to fall on a
lovely couple we see the pair as they're
run screaming towards the camera but
just a split second later when
spider-man is about to pull them to
safety they're instantly facing the
other way and in not much of a hurry
Captain America the Winter Soldier
where are we now for a movie about
top-secret military operatives and ultra
advanced technology there's a pretty
loose approach to geography in Captain
America the Winter Soldier the
filmmakers post the location shield HQ
on screen
although the latitude seems
rekt the longitude is listed as south
when it should be West Avengers age of
Ultron she's a witch although this
mistake may seem minor it's incredibly
jarring to see it play out in real time
as The Scarlet Witch talks to Captain
America in a scene from Avengers age of
Ultron
she's got a head tilted to the left side
of the screen but in the next shot from
further back
she's tilting a head the other way wait
what movie was this again thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know your favorite Marvel
mistakes